Hey, what's going on? Is Bill Burrows
sign for the Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday.
Monday morning podcasts.
Ah,
I'm
just checking in on you. How are you? Um,
it's Thursday,
November 15th and old
freckles is off the road. Hey,
he's dropping pounds right in,
left because he's not up there
eating from a chef. He's Billy.
He's losing his freckles. Sorry. Um,
I'm excited to be home with my wife and
kid. And speaking of which I last week,
last Monday. Can you guys
remember back to November 12th?
Remember that Trump was still president?
He's still president anyways. Uh,
what was I gonna say?
Um, I read a question.
Best friend's wife from a lady and
felt that Nia needed to chime in.
So what did I do?
I got in touch with my wife's people to
try and see if I could put her on the
podcast and she was nice enough
to take time out of her busy,
beautiful schedule as being
the greatest mother ever. Um,
welcome back to the program. Thank
you Nia hill. Thank you so much.
Thank you for having me. Oh, well what
was it like to work with Tom Cruise?
Oh my God,
he is so amazing.
He is just so generous and do his
own stunts. He did his own stunts.
So he really banged you in that
scene, right? Oh my God. It was great.
He didn't let it stop me do it.
No, no. He'd stand commitment.
He stabbed me in the eyes the
entire time. Real. It's like wow.
It's like we're in a real relationship.
After he got to the Invisalign,
you fixed that snaggle tooth.
I just felt like it all just
went to another level. His
commitment to the craft.
Yeah. Excuse me, ma'am. We're
trying to do a podcast over here.
I got the little one out here too.
When she has her favorite show on
the one created by Harland Williams.
I can't say the name of it or she's
going to freak out cause she's kind of
looking at it like,
why is there no sound?
It's almost the 2000 twenties not the
1920s then once you have some old lady
playing a piano when the
corner. All right, Neil.
I know you have a lot of stuff to do.
We're going to do a little Bang Bang here.
Going right into it. All right, great.
All right. Best friend's wife from a
best friend's wife. All
right. Hello, Billy Baldwin.
Oh, hey. I like it. Yeah, but I went
in that I liked that I win. Yeah,
that's bald. And I, when do
I, I don't think so recently.
I must saying, hey honey, speaking to the
mic. He rather than chime in. All right.
Yes. Oh, you're talking about,
yeah, me. All right. Uh,
recently I've been posting pictures
and videos on my Instagram that are not
slutty.dot, dot. Not slutty,
but I wouldn't show my parents either.
Ah, period. Now, where it now, where,
where would you call if you had to
rate that as a movie? Where is she?
What do you mean? Like
some movie PG, PG 13 are,
it's not NC 17,
but it's not me.
If she's showing nip and booty.
So then you would say PG,
PG 13, now somebody's, oh,
um, I am 26 years old. Prime of your life.
And I've been feeling very
confident about myself. Wow.
Add Up Bay Vida.
Show it off girl.
I want to bring that back.
What happened to [inaudible]?
Me Guys don't dance anymore. Bring what
back burlesque. The old stripper song.
Yeah. Dita von Teese does it not in
the club. What do you mean in the club?
The in duck club Da. No, not
we're black duck club. No,
that was never our,
are you going down? Um,
and I've been feeling very
confident about myself and my body.
I'm single with no
boyfriend or even dating
anyways, my friend, sorry, since I was 16,
has told me that his wife
has been uncomfortable with
us talking because she's
seen my pictures.
So they'd been friends since camp.
So what happens at camp stays at camp.
That's right. She, she's told him,
uh, she feels insecure and sees
my pictures even before he does.
Uh, he has the following
here. Yes. She's watching you.
Private eyes.
He has expressed that he may not be
my friend anymore because of this.
And this is not the first time I've been
blocked by male friends because their
female counterparts,
our social media stalking me and
claiming I'm trying to get their men,
first of all, nobody's stocking
you. You're on social media.
If you are hanging these up in your
house and you looked and she was staring
into your window,
you can let go and just be like really
looking through someone's feed and just
be like every time they pose looking and
not only looking at the picture and see
who's liking the picture and the tag,
like all that kind of stuff.
All of that is all out in the open.
I know, but like you can pay like a,
just a little bit more attention to it
then a normal just scrolling through. Oh,
like, like, like it's like a little
kid playing hide and go seek.
The first time they hide,
they lie down on the floor,
face down and cover their eyes.
I'm hiding. You're not hiding.
You're putting this out for
the world to see. And judge,
I've been told uh,
to maybe tone it to tone
down my post or not. Right.
How I feel because the girls take it
personally and take it out on my friends.
Uh,
and these,
are these my real friends or do their
girls have legit reasons to be upset?
Yours truly a huge fan and
love to Nia and the baby. Oh,
um,
well first of all I had to say,
I don't know why you're surprised at
this reaction because you're out there
thirst trapping and these girls don't
want their men to get caught in your trap.
So even though you may not be trying to
break that down for the white audience,
what, what thirst
trapping? She's out there.
Thirst trap trapping means like you post
photos that are intentionally like sexy
or provocative cause you're trying to get
legs. You're trying to get out of this.
Pretend that they're not, you're just, Oh,
this is just me eating cornflakes with
most of my breasts to sit down. No,
I don't think that you're
necessarily acting like it's not,
but you know that there's just like
certain photos that are going to get like
the IEA reaction as opposed to the like,
Aye Yai Yai.
Is there any, uh, d going on here?
Teas, D, teas,
Dixie, you, it's the kids
here. Oh, a vibrator.
Uh,
I don't know that it's a Dt,
but it's definitely like showing
you what your life could be.
Yeah. What you could be throwing around
the bedroom for sure. So I don't,
I mean it's not surprising that their,
their girlfriends and wives or whatever
are going to be like feeling some type
of way if they're liking your
pictures. So, um, I don't know.
I don't think that you're doing
anything wrong, but I didn't write this.
I don't think that, um, there
are necessarily wrong either.
But here's the thing. I feel like they
were going back to one of my earlier,
my earliest appearances on the podcast.
The only thing is she's been friends with
this kid since she was 16, so that's,
they're fine.
But I also noticed in her letter that she
said that like all of her male friends
are most of her male friends.
So it was this another situation where
you've got a girl who's got a lot of male
friends, nothing wrong, no friends
involved, male friends. And it's,
Oh my God, there's stalking
me on Instagram and Oh my God,
there's such haters and my are these men.
Really? My friends, it's like, listen,
you just have to understand like you
have to kind of be a grown up about this.
Like it's one thing for you. Like I
said, the Post thirst trapping pictures,
all your girlfriends are going to be like,
yes. Oh my God, you're giving me live.
You're so a hard look at you,
Bam. All that kind of stuff.
That's what your girlfriends and
like your gay friends are for what?
His thirst trapping me. I just told
you what it was earlier. Yeah. I said,
when you're posting a picture that's
intentionally provocative or sexy to get
likes, that's like a thirst
trap. In other words,
you're not really going to hook
up with anybody. No, you're just,
you just saw all these postings, a sexy
photo. But Steve, for women, lady, uh,
guys are showing thirsty for attention
that Oh, that's right. Sorry.
Sorry. I'm the White Cup on
Sanford and son. I'm rapping.
So I mean, I'm, I'm, I'm just
not surprised that they're there.
What should she do so she stepped away
from these people. I mean step away.
How far away from the car with your hands?
No.
Do you have
to understand that if you start to move
into this space where you're posting
sexy photos, your viewership and the way
people look at you is going to change.
Huge point.
If you're okay with that,
then keep doing what you're doing,
but if you have a problem with it,
then maybe you want to pull
back a little bit, but yes,
people are gonna look
at you some type of way.
Women are gonna look at you differently.
Men certainly are going to start to
look at you differently and certainly,
but go ahead. What comes
with that territory is that
women are going to be like,
oh, I saw you liked her photo when she
was like, you know, bent over being like,
you know, I actually, if I could
just meet cute or whatever,
I don't know what people are here.
They're both,
certainly you're not going to insert
anything. That's, that's what I know.
It's a rough one. Both men
and women equally are going
to look at it differently.
Right. Okay. So let's not, let's not turn
this into yet another, that's what I said.
You said women are going
to look at you differently.
Men are certainly gonna
get your differently.
Yeah. Well, okay,
so just say what you're saying.
Just don't, don't, yeah.
Well, okay, me just, yeah.
I mean I stand by what I
said. You think that, well,
why can't you say that so we can
discuss it? I've been doing that.
Yeah. Well, okay. If Lola
wasn't here, I right now,
I would transcribe what you just said
to me. What's his, what? Huh? I can't,
there's too many f words in it.
That was,
that was like, if you put a bunch of f
words into a shotgun. Right. Well, um,
so I,
women know what other women are doing.
I think you have to expect that.
You know,
if these women are already uncomfortable
with your presence in their man's life,
if you start posting booty shots and all
this other kind of stuff and they see
that they're dudes liking it,
they're going to be like,
she didn't say that she was bending
over and or any of that type of stuff.
She just said, this is some stuff that,
you know, it's a little more risque,
but I wouldn't show my parents.
Right, exactly. Meaning
it's, yeah, it's, you know,
your parents or your knees
get back in house. Priest,
I think you should post whatever you can.
The Catholic church,
if you're feeling good about
yourself and about your body,
you should post all the live long day.
Just know that it's not going to be
this perfect scenario where you can just
post and no one's gonna look at you
differently. I disagree, fortunately.
Unfortunately. That's just the way that
it is. I disagree with that. With what?
With it.
You should go and post all these sexy
photos of yourself and put them on social
media. Women can not be doing that. Why?
Why are you telling women what they
should be doing with their bodies? It is.
There it is. Yeah,
exactly. There it is. Yeah.
And there it is from
you to tell it like it.
I don't think women should
post the like who are you?
You don't get to decide what
people do with their body.
Please not say that expression.
You don't get to just
whatever. I want to say everything
in her dot trying to police my words.
You haven't even heard what my point
is. What's your plan? Okay. My,
my point is bad.
I don't want to hear it.
You have the way you wish the
world was and the way it really is.
Okay.
So to go out there and do all of that
stuff and be all provocative and get all
these people hot and bothered,
there were so many fricking cycles.
That's the same reason why you don't go
out there and as a celebrity sit there
and, and uh, you know, tree stump or
whatever the hell you call it for, for a,
for a candidate,
all you're doing is just going out there
and getting that lunatic in the white
van with the two seats that wants to
make a pipe bomb and stick it in your
mailbox. You doing stuff like
that, you're a good looking person.
People are going to know
you're good looking. Like the,
literally social media has been around
so long that that people aren't even
understanding that there's no
perspective on it anymore. Half of these,
so many of these photos that are on
Instagram and all that type of stuff,
those were like the kind of photos that
were in the beginning of a magazine at a
truck stop like 20 years ago and
these are just regular women up.
But back then you didn't
know where these women were.
You couldn't find them on the Internet.
There wasn't cvs taken. Everybody's, uh,
information and you can go on and find
everybody's address out there and you're
going to go out there thirst trapping
or whatever the hell you calling it,
showing your goods and you're just,
you're playing.
There's not a person in law enforcement
that the would not 100% agree with what
I'm saying.
This has nothing to do with a guy telling
you to do what you should be doing
with your body.
And it has to do with somebody looking
out for your own personal safety.
And the doing that is no
different than these f and morons.
You see out there riding a bicycle in la
on busy streets allegedly in this bike
lane that's not even painted and they
have their headphones on. You have you,
you have completely no responsibility
for your own personal safety.
And then when something happens to you,
this is this a hundred percent looked at
that you're a victim, you are a victim,
but there's nothing looking at
like some preventative measures.
Like why would you go on
the Internet and do that?
Just post a picture yourself smiling.
You're a good looking person and you'll
attract the kind of person you want to
meet.
You're going to go out there and show
your booty crack and you and you in your,
your your, your ass cleavage there.
I mean, what do you, what do you,
what do you like you even said that
if you're going to start showing that
everybody is going to look at
you differently. Certainly guys,
now all they're going to think
is really one of the Fq, right?
That's all they're thinking. That's
the best you're going to get, right?
That is the best you're going to get
with those photos and the worst you're
going to get is an Effient stalker.
Right? Okay, so that's what I was saying.
I wasn't trying to get in your world.
I wasn't over here man spreading.
I'm just saying doing that,
it's literally like becoming a comedian,
posting something on the Internet and
then you're going to get upset when
someone just tears the hell out of
it and says you absolutely stink.
And it's just like, well, you
know, you're not a victim here.
You're the guy who posted your,
you're the person who decided to get up
on stage and people are going to judge
you. That's all I'm saying. And I think
that women that do that type of stuff,
I don't think because there's so young,
I don't think they understand the level
of f and lunatic that is out there.
I don't even understand that
because women get it way worse.
So to go out there and sit there,
I mean that's like when you order the
frigging alligator farm and the dangling
those frigging chickens over the thing
and all the crops go in the water.
You're out of your mind.
Uh,
well I understand your points,
but I still think that people
should post what they want to post.
It's their license
roll the dice that you were in the herd
of people showing most of their boobs. I,
I mean, you're not going to get
flipped peoples. Yeah, I do.
Because I don't think that you should
be living your life and in fear of what
could happen or what might happen
because of that was the case.
I wouldn't leave the house.
I'm not talking about going after a dream.
I'm talking about keeping your
ass crack and your pants. Well,
I respectfully disagree,
but the thing is,
oh, we're going to have a problem when
so and so gets to be a certain age.
You don't, you dare tell her
that that's going to be okay.
We'll see that without it. No,
no, I, no, it's your daughter now.
It's not okay.
I recognize the hypocrisy in this,
but I would be like,
please don't post that
type of stuff on there,
but I also know that I,
at a certain point I'm not going to
be able to control what she does.
She's not going to be sitting here
watching cartoons. What do you mean?
What does that mean?
You know, beyond a certain point. I
mean, what, what, what, what age is that?
What are we talking about here?
When she's 80 and she's an adult,
I'm not going to just, he isn't.
If we could what you thought your, your
18 hours, the logos, you're not an adult,
right? Oh, you're not okay.
You and I get a divorce and I'm with
an 18 year old. What? She's an adult.
You're going to be like, she's a shy. Oh
my God, I would kill you. I kill myself.
But yeah, just because I lost you. Oh God.
Oh, say that no more
romantic. Little enough.
Sweet nothings. I don't even know how
to be romantic, do I not to be romantic?
Um, Oh, you know what romance is?
You're not, you're like a generous
like sweetheart, but like romantic. No,
I wouldn't say that your romantic,
but I wouldn't argue with that.
You like romantic things you
like like music, like dancing,
like in the middle of the house.
Like you like to do stuff like that.
I want to take you to Frankie
valley out here in La. Marque first.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
Can I have a jersey boy
and I have a date mistress.
Someone that totally platonic.
Just somebody that I bring to
all the stuff that I want to go.
You want to find like a 50 year old
white woman to take to stuff like that.
Why you got to bring race into it?
Yeah,
because I mean they'll go see Fall
Frankie Valli heavy. C'Mon lets me,
are you kidding me?
I maybe my mom would go,
where'd she go? I take her. You
wouldn't take my mom. I wouldn't go.
I love you mom.
I'll go in a minute.
You got some probably have a really nice
time. You know, just too good to be true.
You don't want to see that dude. He's in
his eighties he's still kills it, right?
Yeah. That's the guy
from Jersey Boys, right?
Georgia.
Even though what?
On never laid a hand on you as the door.
So anyway, back to the
question. 1 million module,
my Neil's perspective,
my Neil's perspective isn't that,
is that you're not doing anything
wrong by thirst trapping on Instagram,
but you should know that that's going
to come with a change in how you're
perceived. And yes, they
are. Here's the thing.
If I had a girlfriend who was hot single
and she was feeling really good about
herself and she was posting,
you know, sexy photos,
I would be one of the first ones being
like, yes, bitch, get it. Oh my God.
Amazing what? Get it. Get your life.
Just get everything. What is
that? That, yes girl show you.
But if bill, are you doing, if I saw
that bill was lacking all of her photos,
I might be like,
now wait just a minute.
So that's just the reality.
Yeah.
All right. Let's see. I've, I've
finally got my abs. Like I finally,
I didn't have to go on the road for,
you know,
and just ruin everything that I got.
I get my abs back and I start,
I start posting shirtless photos
cause I feel good about my,
I'd be like, yes, yes, yes.
Yeah I would, but yeah, and when
I have a problem with women,
but women already like
are looking for you and trying to
like put it out there. I've seen it.
I see your comments ladies.
My remarks.
That's one of the funniest things you've
ever said. Just no, I'm watching it.
I've never had that attention
ever. Uh, it's been happening.
Perhaps you have a notice it,
but it happens.
It doesn't count when you
get to where I'm at now.
What do you mean it doesn't count?
It counts when you nobody.
That means you good looking above
a sudden you start selling tickets.
Hey Baby.
I was just like, that doesn't mean
anything. Look how good she's been.
You liked me when I was broke.
I did.
I fell in love with you when you were
broke. It was a great time. You know.
I got you.
I was thirst trapping.
That was going to say something else.
Oh nanny.
Um,
all right, well I'll agree to disagree
on those photos. I mean I think you know
what people are.
Yeah,
it's just like you were in inviting like
I would love this gotta be something up
there. Somebody in law enforcement
and stories and all of that.
This stuff that dude, these people
are, I like, people are lunatics now.
Like people will already nuts but this
like this computer with all of this stuff
that you can look at like you couldn't
do like, you know what I mean?
Like down the look back in the day,
Nia,
if you had like a crush it
somebody on work. I mean,
you needed your imagination when you
went home to conjure up some sort of fit.
Now you just go to their Instagram page
and just sit there like an absolute void
or it's not even considered voyeurism
anymore. Right. And you just sit there,
it's weird.
The whole thing is weird.
And he'd go further down and then their
pictures out enough and then you need
video.
And then the video like God,
he's just some weird thing the way she
like cracks and egg when she's just
showing you how to make uh, uh, uh,
over easy egg or something and you get
all of this psycho world and then what
happens is you get so into that virtual
world that if you ever asked her out and
she actually approached you,
you then have a performance,
a prob problem because it's, it's too
intimate. Cause he used to this stuff,
this thing, there is a disease
and you know, I, I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm not judging anybody cause
I felt the ramifications of it,
you know what I mean? Trying to lay
off the, uh, the, the, the, the,
the bad stuff on there. If you know
what yeah, it's, you know, it's, yeah,
it's just too easy. So I'm
just saying, I don't know.
You know, you don't mean yet.
I'm liberal and conservative.
I'm conservative when it comes to this.
You are conservative when a car is,
you know, last call at a bar.
I get a little liberal and
that hasn't, what do you,
what is ty man? Like? What is to
a, um, do you realize that it's,
it's 12 noon in Japan
right now, man. Oh, Jesus.
Okay.
All right ladies as a door do.
Hi. How you doing buddy? You were so good.
You just chill it out.
Excellent.
You watch him? Pj Masks. Pj Mask.
It's the PGA math.
I don't know what she said,
but she said no masks.
Yeah.
Can you say hi baby?
No, no. There's no baby
there. Say Hi baby.
All right. This is my favorite word
she learned all week. Hello? Hey. Hey.
Football.
Okay.
You say football?
She just kissed the microphone. Can
you say football? Football. Football.
I love it. It's two separate
words. Can you say hockey for sure?
Can you see hockey? Yeah. Kashi.
What else? What else did
you teach her? Score.
All right, let me, I gotta
read some advertising. Oh,
it's the family podcasts.
Good girl.
Feel my always was
something and let me read.
Okay.
Some advertisement.
All right.
And other weeds.
Hold my hand.
All right. Oh No. Pop,
pop, pop, puppy dog.
No dog. That's right. You're
watching inbox. Where the hell is it?
Yeah. Yeah. Alright, here we go. Four
reads everybody. Hey. Hey Nini? Okay,
here we go. Zero. All right,
you just do the music bed. All
right, honey. All right. All right.
For any smokers out there trying to
quit or if you know someone who is,
there's a revolutionary way to
quit called zero zero, zero.
Whoa, Whoa, whoa. Zeroes.
Quick Kit is a new quilting solution
proven to increase your chances of kicking
the habit by up to four times
compared to going cold Turkey.
In your own words. Oh sorry.
Capital letters words.
Talk about your experience or experience
of someone you know who was trying to
quit smoking.
Ah Man.
I remember there was this guy and
he was trying to quit smoking,
but he couldn't do it cause it
was too hard. And then he died.
Uh,
no he didn't.
He's still lift and he eventually
quit and I think he went cold Turkey.
I don't know why these people
want me to tell you that. Anyways,
how many times did you slash they try
before you slash they were finally
successful. He tried
a lot. A lot of times.
What method already answered all this?
These zero quick kilt kit not killed,
uh, is a three tiered approach
that includes prescription
medication, nicotine,
gum, and continued support
through a mobile app.
Dare I say this is like
the blitzkrieg. Oh, it's c.
Okay.
Atlanta. Jesus. I almost forgot
the last way. How would you do it?
Okay.
Well the English Channel
said there ain't off.
How the hell would you do the rest of it?
How are you going to get him on
lending and a walk across the water?
How are you going to bring up? How are
you bring up that person during this read?
I don't think I didn't get done what
he did. He had a hell of a battle plan.
I don't think your advertisers,
Hey Rick,
I think we would have rolled right past
it. He brought it up. Here's how it works.
Go to quit with zero.com to
start your online doctor visit.
After your five minute visit,
a physician will then determine if
you're eligible to use the quick kit.
If you're eligible, like they're going
to say no, the doctor will prescribe.
We don't want money.
We'll prescribe your medication and the
quick kit will be shipped directly to
your door. Why is that so hard
to say? Quick Kit zero zero,
zero will cost less than what the average
smoker spends on cigarettes and less
than other quitting options.
Yeah. How come? Well,
how expensive our cigarettes now per pack,
Nia.
Oh,
I thought you were one of those bad girls.
Smoke it in the board room
lies, uh, go to quick with Zen.
Quit was zero.com/bar
and for a limited time,
my listeners can get their first month
of quit kit to stop smoking for just $37.
That's quit with zero.com/sorry B
U R R is all in capital letters.
One more time.
Hey,
quit with xero.com/indochino talk.
Nia.
Talk about how every man looks better in,
feels more confident when he puts on
his suit. Could you do that for me?
Every man looks better and it feels
more confident when they put on a suit.
What does it do to you
when you see me in a suit?
When you see Mike Pasty Body March,
Huh?
No, you look great in a suit. You know,
I like the whole habit dash. Yeah,
I like that whole look. I like
bottom. I like a three piece suit.
I like a nice tie. Good shoes, nice
socks, good trousers. Does that,
uh,
does that increase my chances later on
of getting some sort of physical contact
with the consensual? Of
course, yes. Consensual.
In the old days I could just tie you
down with my neck tie and that would have
been fine. But that was considered
working it out amongst yourselves.
Oh my God. They're like in Japan or
something. That's all right. Yeah, no,
definitely. And I definitely like it
when you wear a suit. Visit a stylist.
What if I wore one of the bedroom tonight?
Just showed up. That's weird though,
because that's not, I would like that
if I just showed up in a suit. Yeah.
Really? Yeah. And you were
like the businessman. Oh boy.
And then they gave you the business.
Yes. Okay. This bit.
This man giving me the
business.
All right.
It looks like somebody's gonna be doing
some business with Indochino. Alright. Uh,
visit a stylist at our showroom and have
them take your measurements personally
or measure at home,
uh,
yourself and shop online@indochino.com
choose your fabric inside and out.
Honey.
Choose your design customization.
Submit your measurements
with your choices.
Relax while your suit gets professionally
tailored and mailed to you in a couple
of weeks. Really folded up
like a frigging pocket square.
Just watch as the complements rolled
in. Oh my God. Look at your package.
November is November is black Friday.
See Nia, you guys get more than one
month. Wow. You get a month in a day.
You get up.
Even our kid knows that was messed up.
Hey,
you get a month in a day
in leap year, that's 30 days.
That's an official month.
There's the first,
you get all 28 days of February and then
that day after Thanksgiving when, uh,
oh my God, are you still on this? People
arrested for apple from all races,
trample each other and in
a department store, no gay,
that I swear to God, that black Friday,
that should be on the discovery channel.
It's like they should do be doing it.
You know when the Serengeti,
when the water starts drying up and all
of a sudden you know you're a zebra and
you're taking a drink next to an alligator
and there's a line on the other side
of you.
It's like those mob movies when they tried
to have a truce and then somebody you
know every like somebody
screws it up. Oh, I'm sorry.
That was the professional I
should've said. Oh, all right.
November is black Friday season
meeting 2018 is lowest prices,
up to 70% off everything.
The theme is all about
stepping out from backstage,
making an entrance takes center
stage, your big moment, grand finale,
etc. This week,
my listeners can,
a of veil can avail of black Friday
pricing by using code [inaudible] at
checkout cal capitals.
That's 70% off the regular price for a
made to measure suit plus shipping is
free.
indochino.com plus Promo
code bar up to 70% off.
Incredible deal for a made to
measure suit. Once you go custom,
you don't go back, Hey Nia, can you read
this thing about a hair plugs? I gotta go
blow my nose here.
Which one hymns wasn't us,
it was hymns and please trash me
in my hairline. The whole hymns,
66% of men lose their hair by age 35
or if you are a certain red headed
comedian a little bit before them.
Thing is when you start to notice
is when you start to notice hair loss.
It's too late.
It's easier to keep the hair you have
then replaced the hair you've lost.
I ask you,
why do guys turn the weird solutions
or do nothing when they can turn to
medicine and science for
hims.com a one stop shop.
A one stop shop for hair loss.
Skincare, sexual wellness for men.
Thanks to science cause your hair
falls out. Doesn't mean you're,
you know what does it work
thanks to science? Well, I mean,
don't they kind of go hand in hand thanks
to science baldness can be optional
actually. That's, yeah,
that's definitely not true.
Hims connects you with rail does.
Have you been with Kimmy that good Lord?
That's definitely not true.
That's right. You came up in the
Michael Jordan era, didn't ya?
When people weren't even bald,
they just shaved their head because
they wanted to be like Mike. All right,
what the hell am I? No waiting
room. No awkward doctor visits.
Save hours by going to [inaudible]
Dot Com answer a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and can prescribe you.
Products are shipped directly to
you. Deal with, uh, my listeners.
Get a free free, get a Triton. Oh,
so I can get a trial of month of hymns
for just $5 today. It's not free.
I was anticipating my listeners get a
trial month of hymns for just $5 right now
while supplies last.
See website for full details.
This would cost hundreds if you
went to the doctor or pharmacy.
Go to four hymns. Dunk, calm her
football,
football.
Picked up the Mike and I love it.
Football in it.
Go to all year in national honey,
go to four hymns.com/burr.
That's no, I can't let
you have it. That's F,
O r a h I m s.com/birth for hims.com/burr.
All right, lastly, but not
leastly, stamps.com football.
Hockey.
Okay.
Football. If I stopped
talking again. Yeah.
Say Go pats.
Yay.
That's right.
Can you say Tommy?
That's right. He's the goat.
He's the best stamps.com.
Can you say Brad Marsh? Ah, there you go.
Can you say Julian Edelman?
Okay.
Can you say Zidane Know Jarrod,
John Michel Basquiat.
Oh, stop trying to be all artsy
openness. Say Josephine Baker.
Can you say Lawrence Welk,
stamps.com stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or
packages at your own convenience.
24 seven print posts you leaving.
And I thought that was cute. Uh,
print posted. Now I got a buzz in the
air. You got to plug the mic back here.
Oh Jesus. This is what happens
when you don't have a producer.
Can she plug it in? Yes. Got It.
I got stamps.com never closes Nia,
much like your legs back in the 90s.
Oh,
I was a high school in the
ninth. Well No. Yes and college.
So.
Okay.
Print postage for any letters
or packages at your convenience.
24 seven print postage for any male
class right from your computer.
The exact amount of postage every time.
Never underpay or overpay against
stamps.com saves you time and money,
which can give you time to grow
your businesses and citizens.
stamps.com brings all the amazing
services of the U s service right to your
fingertips. Tips, buy and print
official US postage for any letter,
any package,
any class of mail using your own computer
and printer stamps.com makes it Eg.
Hey, take it easy. They'll
send you a digital scale,
automatically calculates exact postage
stamps.com we'll even help you decide the
best class of male, uh,
on based on your needs.
No need to lease an
expensive postage meter.
And there are no long term commitments.
And right now you too can
enjoy the stamps.com servers
with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus
postage and a digital scale.
Go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburburarethatstamps.com
enter
burr
are
right.
And that will be the podcast,
the Thursday afternoon
flag football hockey.
Tom Brady.
Say Bye Dada.
Okay, give me a hug. Oh,
that's right. Oh Wow.
All right, I'll see you about it. Thank
you. Thank you for picking up that day.
Very helpful. All right,
that's the podcast. Uh, I
can't say what I usually say.
Hello. I just say a lot of things didn't
I? Uh, yeah. And have a great weekend.
You sees, enjoy the music and then
we'll come another half hour bonus.
What does it from
another half hour from the Thursday
show? Uh, earlier this year. Oh yeah.
Throwback Thursday. Throwback
Thursday. Throwback Thursday.
There you go. All right.
Thank you.
Ex girlfriend's sister. He
Billy Birkenstocks stocks. Uh,
I'm 26.
Um,
and still in love with my
high school sweetheart.
We've been on and off again for 10 years
and I've gone through a lot to say the
least. Jesus Christ. Yes.
I just got back from a two week vacation
with her where everything was perfect
and we had the time of our lives.
This is the woman I want to start a
family with and it became more and more
apparent on this trip.
Congratulations. What could go wrong?
Um,
here's the thing.
I slept with her sister on a drunken
blacked out night three years ago while me
and her,
we're not together and we're on bad terms.
Oh boy. Who? Billy.
My heart was broken and I had a lot
of resentment. I was 23 drunk week.
If shut the fuck up dude,
you had a dick.
You fucking jerked off to her while
you were dating her other sit. Stick.
Get the fuck Outta here. Don't fucking
come at me. I got a dick too. All right.
Don't fuck. And our younger
sister came on to me. Oh my God,
you victim. Things were different
then and I was a mess. Listen,
I'm not saying you weren't
fucking heartbroken. You A, yeah,
you were fucking psych the next
day. There you go. You know what?
You just got to check off a whole family.
Well, you got to love to do
is bang their mother. Um,
okay.
That's got to be called something
like the Grand Slam. You know,
like when tiger woods won four in a row
and they were saying he won the grand
state, you won, you won.
All four majors would be if you bang
the mother and all the daughters,
that would be the Grand Slam. Uh, the
amount of guys. Laughter right now.
Why the women are pissed.
Uh, well a year or so later,
me and my high school sweet,
he started talking again and started to
become close leading up to where it is
now. I had an unbelievable guilt for
what I did with their sister. The,
the closer me and this
girl got years later.
It is the only thing that I haven't been
honest with her about and I had to tell
her, you fucking idiot. No you didn't.
You should have talked to your sister.
And just, there'd been like,
look, what are we gonna do here?
You know,
is it, is it good? How does it make
things better that you told her
that's such as [inaudible] and then like
for the rest of their fucking lives,
that's going to be a problem
between the two of them. Ah, Jesus,
you shouldn't have said Shit and just
waited till 20 years later when the sister
who never got married gets
fucking hammered and yeah,
yeah. Well I fuck jasmine.
25 years ago. And at that point, you know,
what are you going to do? He'd be like,
yeah, it was, dude, I was in the fucking
two thousands. What do you want from me
anyways?
Okay.
He goes, uh, well a year or so
later me and in the high school,
sweet start talking again, blah, blah,
blah, blah. I had an unbelievable guilt.
MMM.
So I had to test sold the
last night of our vacation.
Okay.
Oh my God. We were laying in
bed and I told her everything.
Okay.
I took a slap.
She was crying for hours and it was
his ugly. As you can imagine. Well,
you know what dude, I commend you. You
got it off your fucking chest. He goes,
I feel terrible. And I'm torn on if
it was the right decision to tell her,
my friends are giving me mixed answers
and I would like an outside perspective
from someone who I respect greatly.
Uh,
oh Jesus Christ. I appreciate
the respect me. Um,
okay.
I don't know.
Do you know if it was really bugging
you and you felt like you had to tell a
good good?
You told her,
you know,
now you don't have to worry about that
fucking thing coming out of nowhere.
He goes, it is still fresh and
everything is confusing. On what is next.
We love each other very much,
but obviously I fucked up big time.
Do you think this relationship stands
a chance? I really hope it does,
but I'm worried I ruined it.
She seems to be getting through it
better than I thought after her first
reaction. She me, she loves me, but
I really harder and she needs
some space because when I'm, well,
she needs some space. I hope
you don't have a brother. Right?
Because when I'm with her,
okay,
okay.
She told me she loves me,
but I really hurt her and she needs
some space because when I'm with her,
she can't be mad at me.
I'm not a scumbag and this is completely
out of character for me to do.
I just made a terrible mistake.
Thanks. And Go fuck yourself.
I will say the fact that you actually
feel this level of guilt, um,
uh, you're a better man than me
cause I wouldn't have said Shit.
I just would've just been like,
well,
I hope this doesn't fucking
come out someday. Well,
we're having a pumpkin
pie over thanksgiving. Uh,
and I bet there's a lot of people
out there that live with that secret.
My thing is not only the cowardly self
preservation that I would try to have,
I would also,
I'm also thinking like
this is, I, I would have
handled that situation.
I either wouldn't have said shit or I
would just break up with her and just walk
away from it because
I wouldn't say, Hey, by the way,
I banged your sister and then
for the rest of their life,
they have to fucking deal with that.
Um,
yeah.
When I'm the piece of shit that did it.
But I have to commend you that you
actually felt that level of guilt and said
something, uh, because I, I don't know.
So it sounds to me that
you're going to get past it.
So the good thing is that now you don't
have to worry about that fucking grand
piano fall crashing down on
your fucking life someday.
So that's the upside.
Okay.
MMM.
Maybe there's an upside that you told
her where she'll have faith in you that
like, wow, this guy actually
feels guilt about stuff like that.
So I can't trust them. We were
broken up while it happened. Um,
you know, let me see if I can get Nia
in here for this one. Hang on a second.
All right. The magic of the pause
button again. The lovely Nia is here.
Hi. Hey, how you doing? Right?
Ex girlfriend's sister. Oh,
Jesus. All right. Really quickly,
this guy. All right. I'll
give the abridged version A.
I've been on and off again for 10 years.
Just got back from a two week vacation
with her. Everything was perfect.
We had the time of our lives. This is the
woman I want to start a family with. A,
here's the thing.
I slept with a sister and a drunk and
blacked out night three years ago while we
met, while, uh, while we,
me and her were not together and we're
on bad terms. My heart was broken.
I had a lot of resentment.
I was 23 drunk week and her
youngest sister came on to me.
Oh no, that's right. That's a
rough one. Was a real rough.
You like how he makes himself the victim.
She came onto me. Okay. I said, really?
I said, dude, I have a dick too fucking
lie to me. Exactly. I stopped it.
I said, you rubbed one out
to her before you fucking
yes. The seeds of implanted for a
while that you've been whining a fuck.
The sister don't try to act
like, oh, I was so heartbroken.
You and the sister are both dirty.
Okay, so here's the deal. He
goes, he felt hard, terrible.
The last night of the vacation.
He couldn't deal with the
guilt, so he told her,
he goes, I tell, he goes, I took a slap.
She was crying for hours and it was ugly,
as you can imagine. All right.
She told me she loves me,
but I really hurt her and she needs some
space because when I'm with with her,
she can't be mad at me.
I'm not a scumbag and this is completely
out of character for me to do.
I just made a terrible mistake.
So he's basically saying,
do you think the relationship stands
a chance? I really hope it does,
but I'm worried I ruined it.
She seems to be getting through it better
than I thought. After a first reaction,
what do you think? It's not going to
happen. You fucked her sister. It's over.
That's anything.
So
yeah,
because I mean maybe,
maybe there are some people who are
more emotionally evolved than I am,
but I couldn't get that.
Like that's her sister.
Like her sister is not going anywhere
and like how's it going to be at like
Thanksgiving and Christmas and
like all that kind of stuff.
Like you're just going to avoid each
other or just kind of like, it's weird.
I mean maybe the three of
them can have a threesome. No,
what I was thinking you can't, you
can't have a threesome with your sister.
That's disgusting.
That's gross.
I would never want to see
each other on these bond.
Yeah. Talking to each other. Hey,
I know we went to a waterpark.
Oh No,
stop.
Unless the three of them sit down and
both the guy and the sister are so
repentant and so whatever,
but like you,
you'd never be able to trust them.
You'd never know. He like, Oh yeah,
can you guys run out and like, you know,
get some extra sugar and more groceries.
Exactly. So, and that's the thing.
She might be okay with him now,
but in the end she's going to choose
her sister like that no matter how her
sister betrayed her. That's the
sister. So you are disposable.
You're just like the
dude that's her family.
So if you think that you really like
the hands on to her and the sister, yes,
sister will probably get past it.
Like I have a long,
long ways from now and it'll
probably always still be there,
but because their family family betrays
each other all the time, you know? No.
Here's the thing. I think what she did
was worse than what he did, the sister.
Oh definitely. If we're going to like
put them on, who was the worst person?
That situation?
The sister 100% here's what I learned.
You never do that if you're
with a woman. Okay, okay,
you guys break up and blah blah blah.
If her sister comes on you like
you are effectively ending that
relationship forever. Yeah. Yeah.
And what do you think he should, they
told her, her and the relationship.
You think he should have told her?
The thing about it is,
is that he told her
because he felt guilty.
So it was to unburden his own conscious
because it wasn't real because there's
nothing in telling her that would
make her feel better and oh my God,
thank you so much for being
honest with me. That's the sister.
So I don't know.
I don't really know nothing,
nothing compatible that he had such guilt
that he had to tell her. Not really,
because people are bored with shielding
all the time and they like, oh,
I just had to get it off my chest.
And it's like, great, congratulations.
It's off your chest.
And now I feel shitty.
So was that really for
me or was that for you?
Near Renee Hill coming
in and bringing the law?
Yeah, I, I don't, I don't, I'm
not with that whole like, well,
at least he was honest with
you. It's like, for what?
For me now that was all for him to,
I never looked at it that way.
Wow. Yeah. Not that I don't think
apologies are worthwhile or I don't,
I,
it's not like,
I don't think that you should
apologize for something you did wrong,
but I just feel like you really need to
question. That's what you were saying.
Yeah.
You really need to question
your motivations for
confessing something of this
level. You know what I mean? It's
like what are you really trying to do?
A lot of times people are just
trying to unburden themselves.
Well that's what I was saying,
that the best thing now is he got it out
there so he doesn't have to worry about
that grand piano coming crashing
down into his life someday.
Like get the same way they haven't
like fucking Thanksgiving dinner.
What I want to know is what is going
on between the girl and the sister?
Cause obviously that's no sister.
That's no real. I don't know.
That's what I'm working on.
Something else.
Why that's fucked up is because
now you know that the parents know.
You know, you think she would have told
the parents like mom, what if they know?
Yeah. And then they got to be
like, oh my God, we raised a whore
and I don't think that she's a whore.
She's at a horse person.
But you will make mistakes.
But that's really, yeah,
that's issued. No, no, that's,
that's beyond, that's a power
thing yet it is total power. It is.
I wonder if this was a younger
sister and I wonder like who knows?
But that's what I'm more
intrigued about now.
It's like what's going to happen with
these sisters? You know, that's like,
that's some deep shit right there.
So I don't know.
That's like a power thing on
her thing saying like, you know,
as much as you're into her, you still
can't fucking resist me. What is it?
Yeah,
maybe so because who does that?
Who goes after the lettuce
into the female mind?
I can't let you in on that.
That's not a female thing.
That's like a dirty ass
ho bitch, nasty person. I
don't know what that's like.
I would never go after, uh,
relatives like significant other.
So where do you draw the line?
What do you mean coworker?
So you're not
just so the people know because you
really have strong opinions on this.
So I want to know too. So
family obviously. Yeah. No,
you don't do that. No fee.
If the person that is clearly
in a relationship with
somebody else and you know
that all of that together,
I want to know
no where you draw the line coworker.
Okay.
You guys occasionally have lunch together
with the sisters. Coworker. Yeah.
And there's something the guy's got like,
he does like the,
the Paisley tie with the suspenders.
You know that you guys always
go nuts about that. No belts.
Yeah. Well if you have suspenders, you
don't need a belt. So, but anyway, um,
what if he has both suspenders and a
belt and then you think like what it is
that you're trying to do? Well, maybe
how would you have both when that,
when that like get that thing, that
female thing would like, you'd feel safe.
Like this guy's really going to have,
like he's going to have
an alarm system and a gun.
Yeah. I'm not a sword. And
where to condoms. Yeah. No,
I dunno about that. Yeah, no,
I mean if they're not involved,
if they're not like in a
real relationship neighbors.
Yeah, Babe, would you bang a neighbor
when I Bang like my sister's neighbor. Oh,
not your sisters. Now we've taken
family out of it. I'm saying where,
where is the line where it's just
like, well whatever bitch, you know,
is it that you guys say you put
the hand up, whatever bitch,
what are you talking about? I'm saying,
cause you're saying like that's family.
You can't fucking do that. I was just
trying to find a comedic angle here. No,
I see what you mean.
I mean neighbor two streets over.
Your neighbor knew them,
invited you over and you went over there.
You know what? I have a real life example
of the guy. The guy was an architect.
Okay. All right, I got it. Um,
I have a real life example
of this. During, yeah,
during my prom I went my senior prom.
I love somebody else already.
Yup. Wait a minute. I went with
somebody who was just a friend. Okay.
But my friend has biz
Markie he was just threat.
Um,
but my friend went to the prom with this
guy that she had just met and they were
set up by another friend.
He went to a different school.
So they didn't really like
know each other. The job was
the day of justification.
They was set up by friends.
So I'm totally innocent.
So when you say really we really connected
during prom and like as you know,
that was not what happened. As you
know, my prom did not end that great.
My parents like came and like took
me from this house and I was in,
cause I was dumbing up,
wait to tell them the truth.
I called my parents because I was supposed
to spend the night at a girlfriend's
house, but instead we're going to
be hanging out at this boy's house.
His older sister was there. There was
a whole bunch of us were hanging out.
I was having such a great time that
I called my parents and I said, hey,
just so you know,
I'm staying here.
My mom completely flipped out and she and
my step father came and like extracted
me from the homes. That's how my prom
ended. Exactly. So it didn't end on any,
it was a very traumatic, but ultimately
they did the right thing. Um,
but anyway,
he,
me and this guy ended up connecting
and we ended up like dating afterwards,
so you know, um, oh that's different. I
thought you were saying that, you know,
like I,
we went in the bathroom,
went to the front part of the Limo
and put the window up. No, no, no, no.
But it wasn't her boyfriend.
They had just met.
I think she definitely felt some
type of way about it. You know,
I'll leave because he chose you over her.
Exactly.
You guys didn't have any sorta
like friendship, friendship? No.
She and I were really good
friends. Yeah. That yet. No, no,
that's not good.
Oh, that's a rough one. But it
wasn't a lot of rough, rough one.
And we dated for a while.
We dated up until, you know,
like I went to college basically. And
that was, that was the end of that.
So it wasn't like this law of the
term, you know, Torrid affair.
It wasn't like he was my
first love or anything.
He was just really cute and a football
player and lights Bob Marley, you know.
Hey,
what can I say?
SORTA sordid details here. All right,
well that's the podcast for this week.
Um, need, he came hard
this week. You came hard.
You're really fucking just put that
guy. He just said, you know what,
that and that's it. It's a fucking rap.
And you know what? I think you're right.
I think you're right. I can
say that. Yeah. As I said
to him, like thank you. Yes.
Yeah.
Hey,
what's going on?
It's Belper and it is the Monday
morning podcasts for Monday,
November 15th, 2010. And a,
I'm doing this one really,
really, really fucking late. Uh,
had to fly back from Columbus this
weekend. Columbus, Ohio. And uh,
before I start the podcast, I want to
thank everyone who came out to my shows.
I had six phenomenal shows out there.
Every damn one of them sold out,
people smiling and waving. I was shaking
hands and kissing babies after shows.
Everything was great. So I want to thank
everyone who came out. Uh, seriously,
man, that was amazing. The, uh, Sun,
even the Sunday shows sold out. So, uh,
yeah, definitely. Um, definitely
going to be back, you know,
cause that's how I do it.
If you show up to my shows,
then I come back to your town. Yeah, no,
the fuck you think I'm
doing this for free.
Paypal only the podcast is free.
Um, but even that, if anything free,
there's a price to pay for everything.
My girl is fucking pissed at me right
now because my apartment was so god damn
quiet until I came home and she was
praying to God that I had already done the
podcast and she was asking me, did
you have, did you already do it?
They should do it. And I said, no, I have
to do the podcast. And she was just like,
gosh,
it's just so nice and quiet.
So what I'm gonna do is I'm going to
do a more subdued podcasts this week.
I'm just fucking with you. I live
to irritate people. All right.
So I'm going to be doing it. All right.
What the fuck am I talking about?
I just got off the plane. All
right. Back from Columbus.
What the fuck do I want to talk about?
I don't fucking know.
I'm starting to take pictures of people
sleeping in airports and just some of
the fucking faces, you know,
especially on the planes,
when people don't bring those neck braces,
you know those people like they're fucking
sue happy people during the day and
at night they fly in planes and they
have those little neck braces when,
when people don't have
those, just watching people's
heads, Bob and all around,
you know that's a good time to be
obese because he got like that built in
neckbrace
big neck brace of fat. You
know, you want a pillow.
All you do is just lean your head
45 degrees to the right of the left.
You're all good. I bet they never
have any neck pain, you know?
But what do they do every fucking week on
the biggest loser sitting there, bitch,
Moan and complain it. Oh,
it's so fucking hard. Really?
You have a body temperature pillow
on all four sides of your neck.
I know it's round,
but my world,
you still have sites. So there you
go. Fatties fat people. I know.
And I know I tease you a lot because
you know what? I'm sick of you.
I'm citizens that you know,
there's enough fucking groups out there
that I got to watch what I say that I
got to tippy toe around. Okay? I'm not
tick, I'm not fucking add in another one.
All right. I've added up to here
with the fucking tippy toe and
God damn bastards lay off the fudge.
Um,
I first realized though,
I thought of control when I went to fall
asleep on the plane and I felt like I
was laying on a cloud and I
realized it was part of my neck.
Jesus, how fucking cranky am I
when I get off a God damn plane?
Um,
anyways,
I was a good boy out in
Columbus as far as boozing goes.
I did not booze as far as eating
goes. I did all right. You know,
you know so fucking funny is when you
go to the Goddamn Midwest and you try to
ask people, where can I get
something healthy to eat like that?
There's no such thing as
healthy food in the Midwest.
They don't even fucking understand it.
You know,
all they know how to do is to have some
big block headed fucking blonde haired
kid come out of that
Goddamn wife's fucking Twat,
right?
They don't even raise them.
They just send them out in a fucking
cornfields and just, just have the kid,
the kid grazes until these
fucking 16 all right?
Then they signed them up for
pop Warner fucking football.
They can't even find a helmet to fit
his big fucking big 10 goddamn put your
block of a fucking head.
Right? And then what happens?
Some piece of shit can't beat him.
So what do they do?
They fucking crack one of the crack
back block, whatever the fuck they take.
His fucking needs out.
All right.
His dreams over.
He's not going to block for Jim Plunkett.
It's fucking over.
So then what?
He gets a job at a fucking hotel
desk and here I come walking in,
you know the fucking Pussy,
California boy now going, oh,
excuse me,
is there a place to get something healthy?
And these fucking people there, their
eyes cross. I said, this all, I says,
you know, I'm really craving a stake
does. Is there a place to get a steak?
And I don't mean like an Applebees steak,
you know what I mean?
I'm talking cloth Napkins.
I'm talking, you know,
somebody related to a Rockefeller sitting
at the bar sipping on some God damn
old booze talking to a broad 70
years younger than him. That's,
that's the kind of fucking place
I want to go to. All right,
that's what I want to go to. And you know
what? This fucking God damn idiot sends.
He sends me to some fucking
barbecue shack. I walking
towards it like, you know,
I don't have a car.
So I'm walking around the hotel and
as I'm walking towards the complex,
he told me to go to one of the first
red flags I saw was a neon sign.
All right.
We got any steak eaters out there who
listened to this fucking podcast? Yeah,
the like a quality steak.
Do you like going to a quality place?
Exactly. Now, have you ever
seen a fucking neon sign?
Neon signage?
Does Peter Luger's have neon
signage? I don't think so. Huh?
Smith and Wollensky now it's
always supposed to look stuffy.
It's supposed to look like this.
Politicians in there doing fucking
dirty backdoor deals for fucking defense
contracts. That's what it's
supposed to look like. All right.
Fucking guys in suits.
That's what it's supposed to look like.
And I come walking into this and you know,
I don't have enough time before the show,
so I just say fuck it.
And I go over there,
right?
And I walk into this barbecue joint
and if you guys have listened to this
podcast before, you realize I fucking
hate barbecue. I don't like it.
It doesn't taste good. I think the
sauce is just their way of, of,
of covering up the fact that you're
eating a very poor cut of meat.
You know,
eating the fucking Cartlidge out of a
Goddamn oxen or whatever the hell they do.
The piggers sandwich is it really did
you get all the cartilage in there?
You fucking moron. No wonder you got to
slather it with all that smoked Hickory,
whatever the fire it actually, isn't
that what you cook it with? Whatever,
with all the barbecue sauce.
So I go in there, you know,
and I'm fucking grumbling like
the Goddamn fucking old man I am.
So I open up the menu and I just, you
know, something just pops out at me.
It's says pulled pork.
They got some uh,
some Broccoli and some beans
and I say, fuck it. You know,
he's cute girl comes over, right? Like the
round is tits I've seen in a long time.
It was fucking perfectly fucking
round and they weren't fake.
And I was just kept looking at him going,
how are they so fucking round?
And I was like,
you know what?
She probably has on one of those fucking
Hocus pocus bras. That's what it is.
She's probably got an eight cup,
possibly a B Cup.
And I don't know what the fuck did
doing the padded, but you know,
still it was fun to look at.
She,
she had one of those bras that I think
Doug Henning made and master of illusion,
Doug Henning. Um, he's a magician.
Everybody the big space
in between his teeth,
like that fucking guy used to play for
the giants who's now on television,
who had a failed Sitcom and I can
never remember his fucking name.
Yeah,
you haven't had something like that.
You just can't remember the fucking
name and the same facial hair as Rosey
Greer.
The fuck is his name.
One of the great defensive ends
of all time broke the sack record.
Remember that when fucking Brett Farve
curled up into the fetal position because
they were friends. The fuck is his
name. He plays for the goddamn giants.
Ah, Shit. I keep thinking Richard Seymour.
I know that's the guy that
Patriot shouldn't have
traded the fuck is his name.
Begins with an s.
There's an s in there somewhere.
That guy could fucking,
he could spit a walnut at you between
his two front teeth that even open in his
God damn mouth. Um, anyway,
so I go in there and I fucking order that
shit and I'm just looking at this girl
with their round tits,
right?
And she brings this stuff over and
they got this little, you know,
they got the Kansas City, which is a
sweet, that's a sweet, sweet or one.
And then you got Carolina's more
vinegar base. And then we got,
we got the fucking Mexican one that's
going to make your eyes water and you nose
run. And then they had one other one, the
Pussy one, right? So I go with the kids,
a city one,
and I got to tell you,
it was one of the best fucking meals
I've had in a long time. It was absent.
The pork was absolutely delicious.
I loved it.
The beans were phenomenal.
The Broccoli, of course,
had been steaming since they opened the
place because nobody in the Midwest eats
vegetables. They're horrible people, man.
They all got big heads and block Colin's,
you know, that's why they play
that smash mouth football.
They're not going to use a spread offense.
They're all fucking clogged up.
Ah, just fucking around people. I'm
just fucking around. I'm, I'm, I'm,
I'm going on adrenaline here. All right.
I'm going on adrenaline. That's all I got.
It's all I got this week.
So I actually, I, I,
that's the one time when
I didn't eat well and, uh,
we're going to talk about food this week.
I went to fucking [inaudible], Panorama,
Panorama, fucking Panera bread,
whatever the fuck you call it.
Went in there and I got a
breakfast sandwich. Um, hi.
Sarah can help you down here,
sir. Yes, thank you sir. Come down to this
registered, sir. Thank you sir. Hi Sarah.
Can I help you sir? One of those places
where it's like, did somebody drug you,
you know, did Alec Baldwin of
Panera bread come in and scream,
fuck you at you? You know the
whole Glen Gary, Glen Ross,
and now you're out here with, you know,
just trying to be all fucking happy.
Stop being, you're not that happy. So
anyway, Sarah, can I help you Sarah?
It's Sarah can help you down here. Can
help the next person down here. Sir,
can you down? Come down here sir. So
I go down. There I go. Let me get a,
let me get a breakfast sandwich. Okay. We
have our choice between egg and cheese,
egg, cheese and sausage or
egg, cheese and bacon. I got,
let me get the egg and cheese. What
kind of bread kind of bread do you got?
What did you get the hickory smoke.
We got the salmon flat. Fuck it.
Just gimme week. Okay. Third,
there's no reason to curse, right?
So I get the wheat and uh,
they just microwave this shit. I don't
know. It was one of the most, uh,
it was almost like a, a joke
sandwich, like a prop sandwich,
like the kind of thing that would be
sitting on a plate in the background and
that old show. Uh, what was it?
Peewee's playhouse. Peewees fun house.
Peewees uh,
let's give some kids some acid and invite
a pedophile over whatever the fuck his
show was called. I Dunno. See, adrenaline
doesn't always work. That was a,
that was a shit sandwich and the
story was even shittier. But anyways,
this is the fucking podcast for this week.
I need help from you guys. All right.
Uh, I went out and I bought
some Ram for my computer.
My whole do it yourself kick.
All right.
I know I could've gone down to the
apple store and had one of those fucking
nerds that God damn body odor walking
around with the nerve to have,
you know, genius written
on this shirt. All right.
With their buddy Holly glasses and
that type of shit. And I'm like,
how fucking hard can it be
to put ram in a computer?
That sounds pretty intimidating,
doesn't it? Well, you know what,
I went on Youtube and evidently
it's pretty fucking easy.
Take a Goddamn Nicoletta your pocket,
right?
You unscrew the fucking battery
for some reason you, you a,
you turn right to loosen it,
you know lefty Loosey righty tighty you
have just go right pop out the fucking
battery and there's like two screws.
You remove a band and then there's two
switches and the things pop out like
toast. You take out the old
one, you put in the higher one.
He slammed that fucker back in. He used
to the reverse process and you're done.
But this is the problem.
You need special screwdrivers.
All right?
You need precision screwdrivers.
And I went down to fucking home depot
and they don't have any small enough.
So now that I have insulted
all the tech nerds out there,
where the fuck can I get these
screwdrivers? I have a Mac. Oh,
s x or is that 10 I have no idea.
Version 10.5 0.8 I need some precision
screwdrivers to unscrew fucking three
four bolts. You know, I
feel like I'm going to,
I'm going to put a fucking
heavy in my laptop. It's a joke.
You guys should go on Youtube,
go on youtube and check or go on the FM
podcast cause we'll have this v.com mm
podcast.com we'll have that video up
there. Just look up youtube videos,
how to add ram to your Mac.
And this guy will show you how to do
the whole fucking thing. It's a joke.
All right. This is my new kick. I'm sick
of these fucking guys with their Dickies.
Come walking into my apartment,
charge me all this God damn
money and not one of them.
Seems like there are
any smarter than I am.
So basically they just have information,
information.
Who are the new number two?
Who is number one?
You are number six. I am not
a number. I am a free man.
Uh sorry. Iron maiden flashback. Um, yeah,
I'm sick of these guys coming in here.
Charge me all this fucking money.
I want to learn how to do shit myself.
I'm still trying to get the balls
up to replace the trim on my doors.
I've gotten to the point where I've
watched enough youtube videos where I
definitely know how to get the shit off.
Like most weekend warriors. Oh,
I can start the fucking job,
but bringing it on home,
you know it's going to be hilarious and
or great for my act is when I actually
try to do this shit and fail and then I
have to call another guy over to finish
it because I wasn't man enough to figure
it out myself and it'll be emasculating.
But you know what? I'll learn.
I'll stay. I don't give a fuck.
I don't have any God damned
pride at this point. I'll, I'll,
I'll stand right there and figure out,
look over shoulder.
I'll be that annoying guy.
Huh?
Oh you blue collar guys out there who
fix shit. I did that for a minute.
I used to finish basements.
You know in the fucking worst job you
could ever do is you go into somebody's
fucking house
did go in to finish their basement and
the fucking cunt would be sitting down
there in the basement watching
you do the entire project.
So anytime you made a bad cut,
anytime you know all you know all
the bullshit that's behind the walls,
there's a lot of knee and elbow work
and they sitting there freaking out.
What does that is as
that going to be a pro?
Like when you go to put the fucking
installation and you know what?
I can't remember the fucking
measurements. I was, I was a grunt.
I just handed the dude to shit
and I remember that like the, the,
the fucking installation would go like
80% up the wall and then you just reach
over and break off some more insulation
and stuff it in there and the fucking
Goddamn broads would get so pissed.
Why?
What about that little space in between?
It's not gonna matter.
Why are you here? Do you think we're
going to steal your fucking laundry?
Get outta here. The Fuck Outta
here. That was a bit late then.
You know what's funny is you
just sit there and, and the,
the fucking shit that would go on
between me and the other person I was
finishing the basement with,
you know,
when we realize the person wasn't leaving
do they do, would just be like, yeah,
hey me the nail gun.
And you know you do that shit where,
where like the Douche is behind you,
right?
It's basically he's talking to me.
I can see his face and over his shoulder
I see the person who owns the fucking
house and he turned to him and he'd be
like, hey me that nail gun. And you know,
his eyes would be wide and his eyebrows
to be down, you know, that look like fuck
shit. Um, so anyways, that's probably
what's going to end up happening to me.
So this is the Monday morning podcast.
If the subdued version of the Monday
morning podcasts for November 15th and
guess what? Guess what everybody does?
I stuttered through this fucking thing.
It is November 15th and old Billy boy
here has got 30 days and no Busan,
no booths,
not a drop of fucking booze.
How do you like that for
fucking willpower? It's not
that impressive as well.
Fucking means a lot to me. I was actually
on the plane reading, rolling stone.
M and M is on the cover and he was talking
about two and a half years of being
sober.
And I was thinking,
that's pretty fucking amazing considering
the most I've been able to go 75 days.
You know,
I,
granted I don't feel like I
have an addictive personality.
I just don't want to have a huge fat head.
Although I could use the side of my neck
for a pillow when I get on the God damn
plane. Um, so anyways,
this is the podcast for this week.
Uh,
last week I actually began a new segment
here on the podcast a inadvertently,
uh,
when I,
when I brought up that movie over the
edge and when those kids right in the
school and they locked the police and
the parents and the teachers because they
were having that meeting in the cafeteria,
they lock them in the fucking cafeteria
and then they start vandalizing the
school and the cop runs up and he's
tugging on the fucking chain link fence or
whatever the fuck they put up. And he
can't get out. And this chick, big chick,
like six foot two comes running
by with this giant globe.
She runs by the camera and then comes
running back, looks at the cop and goes,
ate it. You stick in pig. What are the,
what are the most fucking horrific
lines I've ever seen in a fucking movie?
And that ended up inadvertently
creating a new segment,
best lines in awful movies.
And uh,
I got one for Ya. Uh, it
is called shark attack. Uh,
I can't tell you what the line is.
You have to watch somebody sent this in.
I should say it's a shark attack.
Three just, just search. We're
going to have all of these,
all of the ship shit. Sorry up on. I'm
actually apologizing cause I didn't curse.
Sorry. I said ship instead of shit. Um,
we're gonna have all these videos
up on the FM podcast.com. All right.
But for some reason,
if you want to look it up yourself,
if you're a control freak, I understand
that. Go ahead. Make your life harder.
I don't give a fuck.
Go on Youtube and look up shark attack.
Three famous line and I challenge you
to be silent after you fucking hear what
this guy says.
I think I just said what it just,
it's the most, one of the most fucked
up lines I've ever heard in a movie.
And you know that that's the challenge.
Give me a line worst than this fucking
line in shark attack. Three famous line.
And also I was kind of surfing.
I started surfing bad movies cause I
got into that part on Youtube and a a
definitely must rent,
but definite rental for me.
I'm taking a month off here,
coming up around Christmas is
a silent night, deadly night,
part five. I have to watch
that fucking movie. Um,
there's another great one.
Just just go on Youtube and
fucking just look at the movie.
Just look at the trailer for
that fucking movie. You know,
somebody asked me the other day,
he's like, you know, as an actor,
when you're in a bad movie, do you
think you realize it? You know,
and I think on a movie like that,
you'd do. But the scary thing is,
is I think on anything else you'd doubt
because you're so at the fucking mercy
of the music, of the edits and all that
type of shit. You just pray to God.
You got somebody good.
That's what I learned in date night
when I delivered eight fucking lines.
Listen to me talking like I'm in an
inside the actor's fucking studio.
I had eight lines more
than a goddamn extra.
And here I am talking like I'm a fucking
professional. Why do I have the hiccups?
Um, so anyways, there you go. People.
There's 21 minutes where I didn't
talk about sports. All right,
so be prepared to roll your fucking ice.
All right,
let's talk NFL football real quick here.
I went one in three this week,
betting against the spread.
I got my fucking ass handed the fucking
ass handed to me. I knew the second.
Yeah. You know, gamblers out day. You know
like those certain weeks where you just,
you just can't see a winner. Some weeks
you get excited, you're like, oh fuck.
This is easy, man. Like that,
that they'll definitely cover.
They're definitely covered.
Course half of them don't,
but I'm not even talking about
whether you win or you lose,
but you have that excitement like,
yeah, I can fucking see it. Right.
You know you liked that
the black dude who's,
who's constantly shaving
his head and Predator.
I see you over there and then trees,
right. You're looking at it like that.
This week I was more like Tom
Cruise in top gun. You know,
when he loses his edge and he's going,
yeah, Nah, it's no good. It's no good.
You know, turn the fucking playing around
you fucking fag. What are you doing?
All right. And he says, it's no
good. It's not good. I can't,
I can't see anything that, that's how
I was this week. I just, you know,
I looked at the bills and lines
and I just didn't like it.
Hated that fucking game. You know,
those two Goddamn Jekyll and Hyde teams,
who the fuck's gonna show up? You
know? So I stayed away from that one.
I looked at fucking Miami and the
Ravens and something was telling me Chad
Pennington,
Chad Pennington,
but I was like against Ray
Lewis and fucking Ralph Nader,
whatever the fuck the name
of this quarterback is.
If for some reason I can't
remember, Edie Falco, ed Falco,
what the fuck is his name?
Flaco Joe Flacco.
Um, soil. My Gut told me Miami,
but I didn't have the balls.
I didn't have the balls to
pull the trigger. So I said,
fuck that one. All right,
so I bet Tampa Bay, because they've
been working for me and they covered.
And then I just picked two
games where I just couldn't,
I couldn't see a fucking
winner. I bet that, uh,
the Houston Texans against Jacksonville,
I was getting a point and a half. I
said, uh, God damn Jekyll and Hyde,
Jacksonville, who's going to show up?
Texans have been consistent. Fuck it.
They beat the colts. I'm going
with the Texas. All right.
Lose that Goddamn fucking
bet on that Hail Mary Pass.
All right.
But that happens.
And then I looked at the Arizona Seattle
game and I picked Arizona and I said,
no, wait, Seattle, Seattle. I say, yeah,
Pete Carol is not a fucking NFL coach.
And I picked Arizona as I was saying, no,
not Seattle. So I fucking lose that one.
And this was the worst one.
Pittsburgh plays my fucking
New England patriots,
and I was so god damn fucking depressed.
After that Brown's loss,
the Steelers are at home and they're
only given fucking four and a half.
They got that great defense.
They got Ben Roethlisberger,
Joe fucking cool won two super bowls
that held a lot of water
with me. So I said, fuck it.
I'm taking the Goddamn steel is I
bet against my own fucking team.
And I lost that one. I was
my Sunday night show, um,
at, at the funny bone in Columbus
and I get off stage and I'm going,
it's going to be like 17,
three or 17 to nine or something.
Pittsburgh and I get off stage and
it's fucking 10 to nothing patriots.
And I was like, you gotta be shitting
me. Right. You know that sinking feeling.
You're like, you gotta be
kidding me. Really, really.
I lost faith in my own fucking team on
running, be able to enjoy this. Actually,
I still did enjoy it.
It's kind of a win win for me.
Either the Patriots get to
fucking asses kicked, right?
But it helps my gambling record or
they go out and win. But the thing is,
is I didn't bet on the patriots,
so I can't brag this week.
I can't even bring up the fact that we
fucking own the Pittsburgh Steelers.
We are seven and two against those
motherfuckers. The last nine games,
the six time world champion that
the fucking Yankees of the NFL,
the Boston Celtics of the NFL,
the Montreal Canadians,
the ones with the most fucking
titles. We have seven and two. And I,
for the life of me, I can't
figure out why. I remember a few,
like a month ago when all the jet
fans had this stupid green chest hairs
standing at attention, and I was saying
that Rothenberger hadn't come back yet.
And that's the team that's going to kick
the shit out of you or until you beat
that fucking team that,
that's the team that I believed in.
What the fuck happened?
I Dunno. So anyways,
and uh,
being in Columbus,
I actually got to watch the browns and
the jets game and uh, you know what?
I don't fucking Wa the Browns,
like Cleveland fans.
I don't know what the fuck you
guys did to the sports gods.
That's another one of those fucking towns.
It's just like they just can't lose
a game. They have to fuck it up.
You know?
By the way,
can I get any credit on this podcast
for that stat that I created?
Remember I told you, I said Mark, uh,
fucking Sanchez leads the League in
drop inner dropped interceptions.
Any fantasy football nerds want
to start keeping track of that.
I've never seen anything like it.
It's like he's got a little remote control
in the football that went defenders
catch it with both hands.
It's, I don't know what he
does. Like he's, he's got like,
he turns it into a knuckle ball, that
fucking piece of shit. No, I'm joking.
He's actually a good quarterback.
That fucking guy, he threw a pick.
He throws a pic.
I could've caught the ball.
It hit this dude in both fucking hands,
but because Sanchez throws it,
the dude just goes Wallay he took it like,
Yo,
that it was a hot potato.
It just sort of throw it past himself
and then he's like, Whoa, no wait,
I think I want to catch it now.
And at that point the jet def a wide
receiver wisely slapped it to the fucking
ground. You know, I don't
in defense of the jets,
I mean they did miss three fucking
field goals so they should have won it
regulation, but Jesus Christ,
they opened the fucking door.
That's what scaring me about the jets is
they fucking lose games and they still,
when they got luck be a lady to night.
They got that on their side.
And you know what Chet fans,
cause I know you have no idea what it's
like to win a championship. All right?
That's what you need when you
start seeing shit like that.
That's the kind of shit that should get
you excited and scares the shit out of
me.
Because if you mother fuckers are actually
going to be a halfway decent team and
the people are going
to drop interceptions,
I mean how do you stop the,
even when they're trying
to lose a fucking game,
there's still winning games but jet fan,
she got to admit how fucking
insane is that running back.
I told you that guy who was,
I keep forgetting his name,
the guy with the dodge ram grill
on the front of his fucking helmet.
Who the fuck was talking about?
His arms was saying that's why he
fumbled the ball. Oh, that motherfucker,
they will write in field goal.
Just step out of bounds,
protect the fucking ball,
whatever. Here's my prediction.
I think Cleveland very quickly is going
to get over Lebron leaving and they're
going to become a football
town once again. And uh,
I am all for it because I fucking
loved the Cleveland browns in the 80s.
I loved those teams.
Brian Sipe, Bernie Kosar.
Ah,
that fucking orange helmet used to play
in municipal stadium and it was always
like fucking minus 60 degrees,
uh, those games with a shit,
those games with a fucking
shit, um, cardiac kids. Right.
I Dunno.
You know what?
I actually get excited when a team
that that's been bad for a long time,
but actually used to
have a winning tradition.
Like the browns were the shit in the 50s,
right through the 60s.
You know, that's something I should have
looked up. I should have looked up. Uh,
how many NFL titles that they, uh, that
they want. Isn't that fucked up at that?
They don't count those.
You know what I mean?
Like how the Pittsburgh Steelers are
a top the league with a measly six
championships.
It's not a measly because they've
won in the last 40 something years,
but like six championships is all it
takes for you to get to the top of the
league. You know, it's
fucking 27 in baseball,
17 in basketball.
I always forget what the Canadians got.
The Canadians got like fucking,
uh, they got at least 22,
something like that. Jesus
Christ, some fucking French do.
She's going to correct me on that
one. All in capital letters, um,
squiggly lines over different
vowels. Yeah, I don't why?
Why don't they see anybody know why? Why
don't they count those titles? You know,
why don't they count like a mean,
would it be nice if eagle fans could
actually have like 1960 or whatever the
fuck they had?
At least some sort of championship
banner hanging on top of the fucking a
Blimpie subway, sandwich.com stadium,
whatever. Wherever the fuck they play.
Why don't they, why don't they
count those? Does anybody know?
Is this even fucking remotely interesting?
Let's get to the the obscure sports stat
of the week. Somebody sent this shit in,
you know last week I started this topic
by saying how the last time sports teams
in St Louis lost the world series last.
The Stanley Cup final lost a super bowl
and an NBA title way back when they had
the Saint Louis Hawks before they moved
to Atlanta the last four times they've
lost in the finals.
Last Times they've lost in the finals
and all four sports is what I'm trying to
say. We're all from teams all at
the hands of teams from Boston.
There's your obscure staff from last
week and this is the one from this week.
All right. This is the most fucked
up thing I've seen in awhile.
Evidently back in 1973
all right.
The glam rock was going on, right? Let's
give you a little historical perspective.
I think this is right during Watergate.
What did Nixon get bounced out?
Like 74
that's right cause he wanted 72 and then
the fallout was in 73 and then he was
gone.
What else happened?
We got out of Vietnam is a year
before we got out of Vietnam.
And uh,
I know chicks are pretty hot back then.
You know that whole Mary Tyler Moore look,
and that was never in
the Mary Tyler Moore.
She looked better on that
show at that skinny drunk.
He used to fall over the Ottoman.
But Dick Van Dyke,
um, was the other ones, the ones that
did the guest stars and they had,
they had the fucking mini
skirts, mini skirts, you know,
barely hanging over those
fucking Harry muffs. Um, anyways,
there's your historical perspective,
uh,
to Yankee pitchers in 1973 I never heard
of this traded their wives and kids,
they just switched off families.
And this is the story.
According to the Daily News, 1973,
um, Fort Lauderdale, Florida.
March, March, March 5th, Yankee Pitcher,
they call by their last names
here because I guess, you know,
people knew who the fuck they
were. Kekich K, I. E. K. I,
c h and Marilyn disclosed today that they
had exchanged families several months
ago.
Peterson moving in with Susan Keck,
rich and her two daughters and Keck rich
moving in with Marilyn Peterson and her
two sons.
The pitchers in separate talks said
they decided to reveal the arrangement
because too many people knew about it.
Evidently everybody in baseball,
I mean can't really keep a story like
that quiet I guess all around the fucking
spring training.
Everybody was talking about this shit.
So they finally just went
public with it. So, um,
they thought it was time to clear the
air and the 31 year old Peterson confided
that they hope that you won't make
anything sorted out of this according to
Kekich.
I'm sure I'm saying that wrong.
Unless people know the full details that
could turn out to be a nasty type thing.
Don't say this was wipe swapping
his wife swapping because it wasn't,
we didn't swap wives.
We swapped lives. Ah,
Jesus Christ. Look at this guy. Fucking
sprinkle in a bunch of sugar over it. Um,
I guess technically he is right dude.
How fucked up or their children Keck it.
Your Dad just taps out.
Yeah, I'm Outta here.
I don't want to be with you mom anymore.
And you know, you know my best buddy,
he was always over here drinking beers.
Yeah, he's going to be your dad now.
He's going to be banging your mom
when you hear that Moan and just, no,
that's not me doing that
work or right kids and uh,
I'm Outta here and uh,
I'm going to go fuck his wife
and go raise his children. Okay.
How does that sit with you? Jesus
Christ. You want to talk to them?
If they had daughters,
you want to talk about the easiest
chicks to lose your fucking virginity to,
then they go right there.
There they are.
Well them up fellas.
All right.
New Jersey where the forehead resided
for four years requires simply that the
parties proved separation for a
year in order to file for divorce.
It's a no fault rule,
meaning no grounds are required.
You know what's amazing about this
fucking story is how like that you could
actually keep something like this
quiet for a, for a couple of months.
Because if you ever tried to
do any bullshit like this, uh,
today,
I mean Jesus Christ,
three different 24 hour sports networks
and ESPN alone. The first is network.
I mean then you get, TMZ would jump on
that would just TMZ late night talk shows.
They got like 58 of them now.
Oh my God,
it'd be over manager.
Ralph Houk said it was a situation
that he could live with a,
that it would not rip apart his team
and that it still had its best chance of
winning a pennant since 1964.
I always like Ralph Elk fucking kept
it positive and just for the record,
they went 80 and 80 to two games
of under 500 Jesus fucking Christ.
Jesus Christ. How the fuck he
is the top, that obscure stat.
Has Anybody noticed that?
I've been stuttering more and more
as this fucking podcast goes along,
the sun is gradually going down. It got
36 stutter and fucking minutes in here.
Hang on a second. I've got to turn the
light on so I can read here. Hold on.
Just stay there.
Don't freak out.
I'm not leaving you for somebody else's
wife and family across the street.
How to fuck men talk. That was
like the fallout of the, the,
the free love man
society's rules,
man. What does it mean? You know
what's funny is they, they really, um,
I saw a great documentary on,
on hippies because literally called
hippies and it was awesome because one of
the former,
a hippy dudes was really honest where he
just said he didn't like what was going
on and he rebelled against it,
which I totally fucking related to,
but he talked about living
in those communes, you know,
where they were going to start their
own fucking churches and their own
education and everything.
And everybody shared everything.
And He came to the same conclusion that
we all come to is that basically other
people are fucking irritating
and you want to get away from him.
And that's basically what happened at
the commune, at least for this guy.
Like he was hanging out and have
free love and all this type of shit.
And after awhile you just like,
oh my God, I gotta, I gotta get,
I gotta get the fuck away
from these people. You know?
So you really gotta hand it to the native
Americans how they were able to live
like that. It's somehow,
uh, you know why that is,
of course is because they didn't realize
they didn't understand the concept of
having an apartment much
less a fucking door. Um,
that right. That was pretty ignorant.
That's plow ahead. Oh, by the way,
I've really pissed off a lot of
potheads evidently on my podcast.
They think that I,
I am against smoking weed and then I'm
trashing that whole fucking lifestyle.
Why don't you guys go take another hit
off your fucking blunt and fucking relax.
All right? Just because
I, I trashed that guy
who was a pot smoker.
I wasn't saying that weed was a bad thing.
All right. At this point, with
those vaporizers that they have,
it's probably fucking 10 times healthier
than sitting around drinking a six
pack. I don't have a fucking problem.
I wasn't talking about smoking weed.
I was, I wasn't. I was
making fun of a loser.
I was telling that woman
that she was dating a fucking
loser. All right? As a man,
your job is to go out and fucking provide,
you know,
and when somebody breaks into your house
not to shit yourself and to grab the
nearest blunt object and
fucking go brave hard on him,
that's what you supposed to do.
You know me, I would shit myself,
lock myself in the bathroom and
called nine one one of course,
but I can provide God dammit. That's
when he got to fit fucking pit bull for.
Um, speaking of that, I watched
no country for old men again, man.
What a fucking awesome movie that is.
That is just absolutely
phenomenal fucking movie.
It actually made me sad
that we were in descent.
That's how good that goddamn
movie is. Um, but anyways,
so I just know that potheads
I'm not making fun. You know,
if I make fun of some guy
who's a booze bag, booze bag,
fucking losers sitting around
drinking beer all day on the couch,
that doesn't mean that I don't
think that anybody should drink.
All right,
so fucking relax.
Jesus Christ, that touchy got
mellow when you smoke weed. Um,
anyways, let's plow ahead. Hey Edge.
Can you guys basically just admit that
you want weed to be free just so you can
just sit around, smoke it, and not have
to worry about anybody hassle and Ya,
you know,
to use a classic Hippie word,
why can't you just admit that and
stopped telling me about, you know,
how the fucking declaration of
independence was written on hemp and all,
all these, you know, I mean, Jesus Christ,
you can make a potted plant
out of a 40 in empty 40 ounce.
I'm not going to sit there and act like
I don't wish that I want to drink in
public, right? Dude, my brain
shut down seven minutes ago.
I don't even, what the fuck I'm talking
about? I need to start reading again.
Overrated. Underrated for this
week. Everybody. Um, all right.
This guy said underrated banana pancake.
Damn. I made a simple pancake with
bananas in it and I had some, uh,
some great real maple syrup from New
Zealand and it was fucking amazing.
I couldn't believe how great it tasted a,
it never was a pancake guy
and when I used to go to,
and it was never a pancake guy when he
used to go to diners back in Jersey,
it was delicious but
overrated to banana pancakes.
All right. I got greedy. I thought the
first one was so good. I went back,
I made a second one man,
was I wrong?
I ate it and felt like a gluttonous pig.
I should have known,
but I at least for temporary
temporarily forgot.
Happiness comes in spurts and
too much of anything can be bad.
I hate to relate life to a couple
of pancakes, but it's true.
I overdid it and ruin the great
single pancake experience.
A one and it was great. I ate a second
and I felt like shit. Yeah, they go, dude,
dude, batter. Pancake
batter is a edible cement.
That's what it is.
All right.
I told those stories before for all
you struggling comedians out there,
you don't want to blow
a bunch of cash on food.
Go down to Denny's or an I hop
and about nine 30 in the morning,
get the fucking full stack
of pancakes and force.
I don't even know if they make them
anymore with all this talking about
nutrition, I don't even think back in the
day they give you a five and you just,
I just like man versus food.
I just shoved that.
She'd be sweating by the
time he got to the third one,
all that syrup and all that butter.
And then you'd suck down your water and
the Oj and I swear to God you weren't
hungry again to like 10 o'clock at night.
So you got to skip at least one
fucking mail. You know, just a tip.
Just a tip for you.
Let's wind this podcast down.
Let's go short and sweet this week shall
we, uh, youtube videos for this week.
And I'm going to tell you right now,
I think these are arguably the
best fucking youtube videos,
the best cluster of youtube videos that,
um,
that you guys have suggested since I've
been doing this topic because you guys
have, are now actually going
outside the realm of Youtube.
And finding some really obscure shit.
So for all of you,
they're listening at home.
Just go to the FM podcast.com and uh,
we'll have all of these lined up for
you to watch. All right, here we go.
First a youtube video.
And this one right here is
an instant fucking classic.
I absolutely love this guy.
Uh,
this youtube video is called man is
tased mocks cops and still gets away.
I want you guys to watch this because
not only is it fucking hilarious,
but this guy really shows why it's so
important to know what your rights are as
a citizen. I'm not saying the cops aren't
still gonna kick the shit out of you,
but just to watch this guy,
he's actually stumping the
cops on a certain level
because they can't answer his
questions. They got pinned on the
ground and they said, go and sir,
you're underneath the rest. You're,
yeah. Do you realize you aren't ya?
You're aware that you're under arrest? And
he goes, no. He goes, what's the charge?
What is the charge? And
they just kept going, sir,
are you aware that you're under arrest?
He's like, I don't speak the language.
I'm not in your king. I'm not a
subjective your kingdom. Right,
and for the first minute and 20 seconds,
this guy's fucking hilarious. Then
he gets all religious, oh gee.
And then it gets funny,
looks like a freak and then he just starts
singing this fucking song and they're
trying to handcuff him and he is doing
the most simple fucking move with his
elbow.
Really look to see it.
The cop keeps going over the risks
go under the risk over the wrist,
under the wrist, and he just
keeps moving his fucking elbow.
It's literally a two inch move.
He's moving it up to inches and down to
witches in this fucking cop cannot get
the God damn handcuffs on him and
the whole time he's doing this,
he's singing this fucking song.
He's like a poet or something like that.
Then they tased him and as they're
tasing him he standing up and he's,
he's presenting his case because his wife
is filming it. As he's getting taste,
he's standing up going,
I defending myself.
I am defending myself from this
unjust hazing. And then he runs away
one of the greatest youtube fucking videos
ever. This guy is, is my fucking hero.
I love him. All right, and let's stick
with the arresting this week. Uh,
another one is a funny arrest and this
is black dude getting arrested for
drinking and driving. And this guy
is absolutely fucking hilarious.
He is adamant that he was not.
He goes, I haven't been drinking,
but I wasn't driving. I Sat, I
was drinking, I wasn't bribing.
You gotta see this guy,
I'm shoving it in multiple.
I will take no motherfucker test.
And then they, and as he was yelling,
the lady would be like,
sir. And he just go, Yo,
why am I trying to reenact these?
These are all fucking hilarious and um,
be fair and balanced.
We've got a drunk black guy.
Now we got a drunk fucking white dude,
uh,
drunk redneck arrest and this guy
isn't drunk. I guess he is drunk,
but he's fucking,
he's one of the angry as he says,
the mean is shit ever. The
cops going to arrest him. Um,
I'll just give you a little
quick little youtube trailers.
They go to a rest of the guy and they
already got them fucking handcuffs in the
cops going, listen, now, c'mon
man. We don't want to have,
we don't want to have to hurt
you. And guys like, I know,
I don't want to have to hurt you either.
Break your fucking neck.
Oh fuck it. I can't make up funny. Just
go watch them. Um, oh. Silent night.
Deadly night, part five. Watch that movie
trailer. Um, for those of weak of stomach,
do not watch this reporter
Shit herself during interview.
She has on white pants
too. Just to warn you. Um,
and what is the last one? Oh, the last
one for all the drummers out there,
I had a bunch of musicians,
uh,
specifically drummers send me all these,
all these emails this week.
I had no idea the amount of musicians
and the amount of drummers in particular
who listened to my podcast. Everybody,
yeah, you got check out Stewart Copeland,
Danny carry all these fucking
people actually read something.
Rolling Stone about Phil
Collins Today and, uh,
for as much shit music
as he made in the 80s,
like that guy's a fucking a
fucking beast of a drummer.
Left handed drummer, still plays
those concert toms with the no bottom,
no bottom heads. This guy, I'm
telling you, there's not enough.
If anybody's got a great youtube
video that just has him just playing,
I don't want to hear him solo in with
Chester Thompson who was another great
drummer.
I just want to hear him by himself.
That guy is a fucking beast.
And the sad thing is he stepped out
behind the kit and it was good in the
beginning and then the end,
it was just,
you can't hurry love since since studio.
Just some of the worst
fucking music ever made. Um,
and they're actually actually
check out rolling stone.
He has this whole article with it.
He's talking about how, you know,
he became the antichrist and he's
actually confused as to why that happened.
So I kind of felt bad for him as
an artist, but it's like, you know,
look back on that music filled.
Do you really think that fucking holds up?
She seemed to have at a vigil,
both Todd,
Oh,
oh Jeez.
Terrible music. Um, anyways,
so checked. So somebody,
everybody was sending me these videos of
drummers telling me all this shit that
I should check out. And uh, this was the,
this was the drum video that really
stood out for me. Um, two things.
One,
this is a video I already knew about.
If you guys are into like drum and bass
music or if you're drummers out there
and you wonder where that fucking music
came from. This is video that explains,
says a video video,
explains the world's most underrate,
most important six second
drum loop. And it's, um,
it's basically this,
this song from a sort of obscure,
I guess rnb group called the Winstons.
And uh,
they had this song called amen brother,
which was actually a B side and it had
like this, uh, I don't know what it was.
It was like,
I don't know musically how to say it was
like a fucking two bar drum break that
these, uh, I don't know if people
used to rap over it or what.
They explained the whole fucking thing
and basically how Dj's took that toolbar
drum brake and isolated every sound of,
of, of the recording, every like,
I don't know how to musically,
like if you could cut it down to like
32nd notes, they just isolated everything,
the sound of the ride cymbal,
the sound of the bass drum,
everything and the sign of all of it
together and just splice the whole fucking
thing up and then re
edited it in different,
in a different order and then
sped the whole fucking thing up.
Created all these new drum beats and
car and sped the whole fucking thing up
past the point where human beings could
actually play drums at that point.
But what's great about fucking human
beings is I like to believe is that we're
better than fucking machines.
So the great dramas of the world's
figured out how to fucking play that fast.
That's a whole nother thing guys.
Like Joe,
Joe Mayor actually through fucking cause
these different techniques to play in
molar method,
push pull and all that.
They figured out how to
fucking play at that level.
But this video explains basically how
all that drum and Bass Shit Kinda came
about. And a checkout, Joe, Joe Mayor,
it's another drum video we'll
have up on the MN podcast.
If you're interested in that shit,
how,
how fucking fast this guy can
play and single bass drum players.
I got to show you this fucking video.
This guy can get three and
four bass drum hits in a row,
like broke, broke, broke, like
doing like that heel toe shit.
It's fucking unbelievable. It's unfucking
believable how this guy can do that.
Um, anyways, I know I'm
born in a lot of this is,
this is even more fucking
obscure than sports. But anyways,
that all the drum videos you guys sent
me, a lot of them I knew. And one,
this is the one that I was the least
familiar with because I figured everybody
knows Danny carry in a tool and
all those major bands. But, uh,
this, this band called Russian circles,
which I had never heard of. Um,
and they have a drummer called
Harper Louis and there's a,
there's a youtube video called
Russian Russian circles.
Harper Louis a live at
wicker park fest oh seven.
And it just starts off with, you
know, he just, this fucking guy,
if I could play drums at this guy's
level, this dude's basically, you know,
as much as you want to be the guy hitting
fucking 8 million drums and smashing a
gong that's on fire,
when it really comes down to what you
want to be able to fucking be this God
damn bad ass and still be
playing for the song. It's like,
it's kind of like that David growth thing.
He's another fake,
the drama that David Grohl did on
Queens of the Stone Age. It's like,
it kind of reminds me of
that. It's like he just, Ah,
it's fucking unreal. The whole, it's
all there. It's all fucking there.
The dynamics, the building,
the excitement plane,
not getting in the way of
anybody else he's playing with.
He sees the fucking shit.
Um,
and I got to download some of this shit.
So if anybody knows what their
best album is, Russian circles,
please let me know when I'm downloading
that shit this week. Cause uh,
I fucking the drummer alone, I got, I
got to listen to more of this stuff.
All right. I know I'm babbling on here.
I'll, we'll end with this this week.
All right,
a little bit of advice here.
Listen to this fucking situation. This
guy got himself into, um, all right, Bill.
My girlfriend is 10 years older than
me. Oh, Jesus. She has two kids.
Oh Jesus.
And has been married and divorced twice.
Dude, what the fuck? I'm 26.
Jesus Christ college graduate.
Has any of this made any sense to any
of you? Would anybody else be out there?
26 college fucking graduate.
Have a girlfriend 10 years older than
you with two kids who's been married and
divorced twice. Good God man. He goes,
I consider myself somewhat intelligent.
I'm sure you are, but
not in this area. Um,
by that I mean you should have no problem
understanding this email. Well, yeah,
I know everybody trashes me.
I know,
I know I'm the worst when it comes to
reading this shit. So anyways, here we go.
He says,
four weeks ago I found text messages to
some dude on my girlfriend's phone that
although innocent enough made it clear
that whoever she was texting was on more
familiar grounds than just some
work colleague or a friend,
Jesus Christ. Dude, is that
going to be a happy ending here?
I confronted her about it
and it predictably led to
a lot of finger pointing.
We went back and forth and if and uh,
for a few days and air it out our
grievances, but it seemed agreeable.
Now he bakes I guess point number two,
two oh two more weeks
passed by and Lo and behold,
I find more text messages
from the same fucking guy.
At first I tell myself,
okay,
maybe she can't break things off with
this dude so quickly, Jesus Christ,
who you know, sometimes liberal
thought is a, is a great thing.
Like let's have a fair fucking trial for
somebody before we hang them from the
nearest tree.
But then this times it's fucking stupid.
This is just liberal thought to the,
I mean,
how much of a benefit of the doubt can
you give somebody, you know? So he goes,
so I confront her about it and this leads
to another round of finger pointing.
At which point she tells me
to pack my shit and leave.
I'll do it. I'm gonna tell you right
now before I read the rest of it,
that's fucking great. You didn't have
to do any dirty work. You're out.
You fucking out. So anyways, he goes,
were separated for a week when she
asked me to come back and move in. Dude,
this chick is a fucking psycho. Here we
go. We talk about our future together.
How, sorry she is to have done
that to me, et Cetera, et cetera.
For Fuck Sakes.
We even talking about getting married
when things finally fucking evened out.
I was full of piss and
vinegar and felt vindicated.
Vindicated that I was the one wronged
in the whole situation and that she was
actually making good by
taking responsibility for
what she had done through
taking responsibility would have been
fucking after he do the second you see
those weird texts, just get,
I'm telling you right now,
just get out of the relationship.
There isn't, oh, sorry.
Sorry about that. Now that that's
it. It's over. It's fucking over.
Um, but whatever, you're 26, I
guess you still haven't learned.
I was dumb in my 20 self. Here we
go. Let's read the rest of this. Um,
all was well and good until she
didn't come home this Thursday night,
November 11th. She came in Friday
morning with no explanation, no apology,
no nothing.
She asked me to give her some more time,
but I decided to cut bait and just
get the fuck out of this situation.
Hang on a second, everybody. Sorry.
I had to give him a little applause.
Break there.
Of course,
now I'm wracked with guilt of leaving
the woman I loved and live with for the
past five fucking year.
You got what her when you were 21 dude,
she was 31. Wait, let's do the
math. She was 31. You were 21.
She was already married twice.
All right.
This chick's is psycho and you know what
that means? She's fucking great and bed.
You were 21. She fucking devastated
you with fucking her pussy,
right? Best blowjob. You have a
had. Isn't that what happened?
And next thing you know,
you have to fucking too young and dumb me.
The of you fell for
Jesus Christ.
He stayed there for five fucking
years. So anyway, I guess just check,
still calling them. Tell him she
still wants to get back together.
I feel like every time I sack up
and do what I think is best for me,
she wants me back. And every time what
I do, what's best for us as a couple,
she uses that as an opportunity to
fuck with me all over again. Yes. Yes,
you're absolutely right. Listen
to your gut. This guy, see,
he knows the fucking answers. He's
listening to his gut. Good fucking man.
Um,
is this,
is it just that chicks can handle a guy
that is emotionally invested or do I
just happen to be dealing with one of
those sociopath's that doesn't give a fuck
what she does so long as it
suits her in the moment. Yes.
This plenty of fucking good women.
That was not plenty.
Goodwin's there's good women out
there. All right? Just like good.
A good man's hard to find this. Finding
a good woman's also difficult. All right.
But no, you happen to be dealing with an
absolute fucking sociopath. All right.
She had a fucked up childhood. Something
happened to her. She got touched.
Her fucking dad took off. I don't
know. Or She just got the fucking,
she got one of those bad brains.
You know,
I began to tell you guys my
theory on that, the a brain,
the bee brain and the sea brain, the
brain is the genius to be brain is the uh,
oh, he's a good fucking shit. You know?
Fitzy and then the sea brain is
your fucking mouth breathing moron.
All right.
And when it comes to being a sociopath,
that's like just a, that's just
like getting an option on the car.
All brains come with that option.
It's all available like satellite radio,
you know, you get satellite
radio in a fucking Bentley.
You can also get it my fucking Prius.
All right,
so did that make any fucking sense?
You got a sociopath with the fucking,
she could even have the a brain.
That's the sad thing about
having a fucked up childhood.
She could actually be a fucking genius,
but she's got the sociopath shit.
So tell her go call fucking doctor drew.
All right?
And you get the fuck out of the
relationship. So anyways, he say,
I'd imagine you'd agree that
I did the right thing. Uh,
but it always helps to get a little bit
of press, better perspective on it. Dude,
I totally understand.
You've been in a five year relationship,
you're emotionally invested in this shit.
So you know what the right thing to do is,
but your emotions keep fucking with you.
All right?
So what you got to know is just look,
going through a breakup is painful.
All right?
It's not going to not be painful,
but just because it's painful doesn't
mean that it's not the right thing to do.
You are 100 fucking percent
doing the right fucking thing.
Your 26 year old years old, you're in the
prime of your fucking life. All right?
Get out of that situation. Okay.
She's 10 years older than you.
By the time you're 29, she's going to
be hitting fucking menopause, all right?
Or something like that.
Whatever. Sliding into it.
I have no fucking idea what
she's going to be doing.
She's to be wearing those mom jeans
at that point if she's not already,
which I don't think she is. She's
probably that fucking, you know that,
uh,
that anorexic cougar look,
you know where they got a varicose
vein in between their fucking,
you can see their breast plate, uh,
Jesus Christ will stay on topic. Yeah.
So to just get out of that, hang out
with your fucking Fellas, you know,
hang out with your buddies. Go out and
fucking have some beers. Join a gym,
get fucking shredded. Go Out, start
talking shit when you're ready.
But don't go back to that man.
You dodged a fucking bullet.
The fact that you were with her for five
years and you didn't knock her up and
you got out of it, and even after
five years, you're only 26 years old,
you made the best fucking move
you're going to make. All right.
And now this is what you need to do.
You've been in a
relationship for five years.
You need to be single for at
least a fucking year and a half.
And I don't mean just be
single and fucking booze.
Figure out what the fuck you looking
for. All right? And when you meet a girl,
if she doesn't have it, just
walk a banger and leaf. You know,
there's nothing wrong with
having a good fucking time,
but do not get sucked into another fucking
relationship because you're going to,
cause you're going to have to go
through this shit again. You know? Well,
you just sit there and you
know what's fucking wrong,
but you don't want to go
through the fucking pain of
it and you keep coming back.
It's a fucking nightmare. It's a
fucking nightmare. Good for you, sir.
I'm fucking proud of you.
He did the right thing.
You sorta a fucking wavering cause
you're going through the motions.
You're only 26.
She got with her when you
were 21 is probably your
first major fucking break up.
So it's acceptable that you fucked
up and went back that second time.
But do not go back again and if any your
fucking friends are listening to this.
Don't let them do that shit.
All right.
Time to a fucking bar stool and start
throwing drinks down his throat. Ah,
that's it. That's the Monday morning
podcast for this week. Uh, anything else?
Where am I going to be this week? Oh,
this week I'm going to be at the uh,
the listener theater in Washington DC.
There's only a,
I believe, oh, under a hundred tickets
left. I'm doing a bunch of radio,
so if you want to come out,
please come out.
I'll be hanging out afterwards doing a
meet and greet. I have my brand new DVD,
let it go. I'll be signing up, taking
pictures and all that type of shit. Uh,
Saturday night I got two
shows at comics at Foxwoods.
Both shows are sold out,
but for those of you who have tickets,
I will be showing up with my
DVDs afterwards, shaking hands,
sign and DVDs, doing all
that bullshit. And, uh,
thanks to everybody's been
coming up to me after shows,
telling me how much they've a, that they
liked the, uh, the podcast and a joy.
My latest special really means
a lot to me. And, uh, that's it.
You guys all have a great week. A, sorry,
the podcast is so late this week and die.
That's it. Go fuck yourselves. See? Yes.